Skandale von deutschen Hooligans in
Nizza Anhänger des ersten fC Köln die
brutal auf die gegnerische Fan-Kurve
losgegangen sind das waren Gewalt 10
Minuten lang 4 Wochen liegt das jetzt
zurück ein Fan der dort im Stadion von
Nizza dann 5 m in die Tiefe gestürzt ist
das alles hat sich damals vor dem
Anpfiff abgespielt und jetzt vier Wochen
nach diesen schrecklichen Szenen am
Rande des Fußballs die Reaktion der
deutschen Polizei ganz ungewöhnlich in
diesem Ausmaß nämlich eine Razzia in der
Hooligan Szene heute früh und bildchef
Reporter Frank Schneider war dabei bei
dieser Razzia vor wenigen Minuten in der
Hooligan Szene guten Morgen Frank das
ist in dem Ausmaß ein ungewöhnliches
Eingreifen der Polizei
ja absolut das muss man sagen es hat so
noch nicht gegeben und man muss sagen es
ist ein klares Zeichen in die Szene
sowas duldet der Rechtsstaat nicht da
machen wir nicht mehr mit das sind
gemeingefährliche Straftaten da wurde
mit E-Scootern geworfen auf Menschen da
viel ein Fan von der Tribüne da wurde
mit Stöcken mit Messern aufeinander
losgegangen und jetzt hat die Polizei
muss ja sagen mit nur vier Wochen
Abstand mutmaß ich 16 Tatverdächtige
identifiziert aufgrund von
Videoaufnahmen und Hinweisen aus der
Szene und hat dann heute morgen um 6 Uhr
zeitgleich zugeschlagen das war eine
Razzia wie wir sie sonst von Rock
Antenne und das war jetzt gegen Fußball
Hooligans die Spezialeinheit BFE war
auch dabei schwer bewaffnet maskiert
sind sie in die Häuser gestürmt unter
anderem wir können das einmal hier
zeigen auch wenn es sehr dunkel ist in
dieses große
Mehrfamilienhaus muss schon fast sagen
Hochhaus im siebten Stock wurde eine
Wohnung gestürmt und dort wurde eine
Person vorläufig festgenommen es gibt
wohl gegen fünf dieser Person die heute
morgen festgenommen worden sind sogar
schon Haftbefehle die sollen auch heute
vollstreckt werden da geht es um
Landfriedensbruch da geht es
ungefährliche Körperverletzung und die
Polizei wird auf einer Pressekonferenz
noch weitere Details bekannt geben also
das ist organisierte Kriminalität Frank
so wird das auch verhandelt jetzt
absolut und man muss sagen die Polizei
wirklich alles reingeworfen was sie
hatten sie haben sogenannte szenekunde
Beamte das muss man kurz erklären das
sind die Beamten die bei jedem
Fußballspiel dabei sind die natürlich
ihre Pappenheimer ich will sie mal so
nennen kennen die genau wissen wer sind
die Problemfans wer randaliert wer ist
adelsführer und die war natürlich auch
in Nizza vor Ort und konnten ungefähr
zuordnen wer könnte da beteiligt gewesen
sein und dann wurden sogar sogenannte
super Recognizer eingesetzt das sind
Beamte die sind besonders geschult die
können anhand von Videoaufnahmen sich
Gesichter einprägen und die später auf
Fotos oder ähnlichem identifizieren und
da hat die Polizei eine richtig Soko
gegründet und hat jetzt innerhalb von
nur vier Wochen 16 Tatverdächtige
ermittelt und dann heute morgen wie
gesagt mit vereinten Kräften
zugeschlagen es gab 13 Objekte hier in
Köln und drei im Umland wo eben alle
Personen festgenommen wurden die werden
jetzt alle zum Polizeipräsidium nach
Köln gebracht werden dort vernommen ob
sie wirklich mit der Polizei reden das
ist ja auch ein eisernes Gesetz in der
Szene das passt zu dem was du sagtest
mit organisierter Kriminalität das muss
man natürlich abwarten solche Szenen wie
von diesen Köln Anhängern Advents kann
man ja nicht sagen dort in Nizza das
haben wir eigentlich jahrelang ja nicht
gesehen und jetzt seit einigen Jahren
immer wie viel mehr Gewalt wieder in
diesen Stadien die Polizei hat offenbar
ja jetzt den Eindruck Frank härter
durchgreifen zu müssen Zeichen setzen zu
wollen dort in die Szene rein
ja jetzt ganz spezifisch hier für Köln
natürlich auch vor dem Spiel gegen Party
sein Belgrad was morgen ist will man
natürlich ein klares Zeichen setzen das
nicht wieder zu neuen Ausschreitungen
kommt auch so wie ich gehört habe der fC
Köln hat sozusagen auch die Schnauze
voll denn sie sollen 100.000 € bezahlen
sie haben für zwei Auswärtsspiele
fansperre und man muss ja sagen in Nizza
waren tausende friedliche Fans es sind
ja immer nur wenige die randalieren aber
die dann eben diesen Fußball und dieses
Fußballfest kaputt machen und da will
man jetzt einfach nicht mehr mitmachen
wir haben das ja nicht nur beim FC Köln
wir hatten das jetzt auch bei Frankfurt
Dynamo Dresden jetzt wieder schwerer
Randale man hat auch so ein bisschen das
Gefühl Corona hat ja nichts mehr
zugelassen es gab keine Fans in den
Stadien es war eine trügerische Ruhe
muss man fast sagen zwei Jahre lang und
jetzt wo sie wieder sozusagen zur
Auswärtsspielen fahren können ins
Stadion können als wenn sich da so eine
aufgestaute wo dann aufgestauter hast
entlädt und das hat mit Fußball nichts
zu tun du sagst es sind immer nur einige
die das dann alles kaputt machen das
zeigen ja diese Bilder da aus dem
Stadion von Nizza der große Fanblock der
Kölner Fans ganz friedlich freuen sich
einfach auf den Anpfiff auf Fußball und
dann machen einige Anhänger das völlig
kaputt jetzt also die Razzia in der
Hooligan Szene und exklusive
Informationen von unserer
bildchefreporter Frank Schneider danke
dir
gerne
[Musik]